i'm only eating meat for the next 30
days
which includes things like raw liver raw
kidneys brain even raw testicles
starting with a barbecue having some
friends over i'm looking forward to the
next 30 days i love this diet already
talk to me in a week taking that bacon
fat now i'm having a pound of salmon
this so-called carnivore diet promises
insane health benefits so took health
tests before and after and the changes
were mind-blowing what are your thoughts
on me starting the carnival diet i don't
think it's great because diversity is
the name of the game i think you might
get tired of eating meat once you see me
with a full beard you're going to be
like i'm going to get on the carnival
diet too there are countless stories of
people who transform their health with
this being full of energy curing all
sorts of problems even things like
depression and anxiety but how could
this possibly be healthy
some to doubt whether this is actually
healthy so far i'm not sick of bacon i
wonder how much money i'm spending in
total throughout this whole month oh my
goodness after taking a bite of that my
burrito tastes like cardboard so making
five pounds of ground beef are you
really gonna eat all that uh is that a
problem i feel kind of drained and tired
i think it's carb withdrawals this is
when things get interesting because i
recently met hudson who has crohn's and
incurable autoimmune disease and he's
been looking for a solution it
essentially affects your digestive tract
i've been to the hospital multiple times
pumped with medicine a tremendous amount
of pain regardless of the steroids that
they pumped me with they're trying their
best to avoid complete surgery removing
the colon and then you'd have a ostomy
bag where i mean no one wants to have
that and i connected him with brian an
animal based expert who might be able to
help i think carnivore would be a life
changer for you and i know dozens of
people that completely reverse their
crohn's disease i don't know i've had a
lot of contradicting advice over the
years i've had vegans be like this is
exactly how you should eat and i know
i'm just one of those guys in the mix
people with ibd ibs crohn's colitis this
is like the core of the carnivore
community because they find the most
healing from it and it changes their
life
for me personally meat has always been a
little bit more hard to digest by the
way how often do you work out i only
work out for 25 minutes twice a week
maybe we should trust him
so
are you in
i'm in really
dude all right so hudson got his doctor
involved to supervise it and i really
hope this works because i stumbled upon
this diet because i have someone close
to me who has two autoimmune diseases
who i don't name you know i've been
looking for a solution and researching
stuff but i feel like i can't really
help him but if this works
it might open his mind and it could be a
lifesaver but house is healthy where do
you get your vitamins so i went to this
organ meat tasting dinner where people
had some answers that's alright with
sauce these are actual pig ears yeah
it's pieces no
yeah it's a delicacy it's not a pieces i
believed you oh here we go this is the
heart it's actually really good oh
pickled pig ear so slimy it's moose
liver
so instead of eating veggies you eat
this what are the best organs liver
liver
specifically liver is the ultimate
superfood out of 30 micronutrients and
vitamins we need nothing comes even
close to beef liver i was gonna have to
get used to eating organs so this was a
good start i had ibs for i guess about
like seven years i went carnivore to
like cure it and it basically took away
all my symptoms but what about all the
studies showing you should eat less meat
and more greens research is the most
bought and paid for thing on the planet
so this is something i want to dig in
deeper have we been lied to all this
time and whose advice can we actually
trust but so far not much changed three
days in now how do you feel i feel good
right now in many ways this diet made
things very simple check out this
shopping basket got a beef liver snack
pork rinds bacon ribeye steak disgusting
what is this is this yours show me the
way it is this is chicken liver you
didn't like it you took a huge spoon
it's something you taste a little bit oh
you tell me that now it's been five days
i'm still not sick of it
did you hear that so this morning i had
to rush to the bathroom
diarrhea is one of the biggest hurdles
to try on the carnivore diet if you can
overcome this you can overcome anything
a lot of people on reddit agree the
first two weeks are the don't trust a
fart period as the body is adjusting to
this new diet in the meantime i wanted
to dig deeper now i'm going to be
meeting with paul saladino a medical
doctor who used to be raw vegan and has
been animal based for years now and he's
quite the character
nice to meet you good to meet you
brother michael animal based i think it
is the single most evolutionarily
appropriate species-appropriate diet for
humans for people that aren't familiar
with an animal-based diet it's organs
meat fruit honey and some raw dairy
performing optimally feeling good more
energy more libido better sleep better
mood the eczema goes away when i went
carnivore raw vegan 14 or 15 years ago
for seven months 25 pounds of lean
muscle mass lighter horrible gas to the
point that i couldn't even keep a
girlfriend you can't go to movie theater
because you fart in the cushion
you're doing silent but deadly but then
you get up it seems like you are at war
with vegetables what happened in your
childhood with vegetables
there's no question that plant leaves in
general are full of toxins this is all
plants trying to say leon stop eating me
it's a protective mechanism yes but
there is a subset of leaves that we have
sort of domesticated and detoxified
enough that we can put them in the
grocery store whether that's leaves or
stems or roots or seeds you can get all
of the nutrients in those foods in
animal foods with none of the toxins in
those vegetables look at the unique
nutrients found in meat and organs that
are not found in any plants creatine
carnitine choline carnosine answering
taurine k2 b12 biotin riboflavin that's
always a complicated thing does that
make sense yeah it's a lot for youtube
so to keep people engaged let's just
play a funny clip
you drink blood i do and you need
testicles yeah
raw yeah
and then he invited me to have some of
course i couldn't say no that is a big
testicle that's half
that is half
god i don't think i can do this you
probably can't
maybe i can't i don't think you can what
do you want to bet i'm gonna eat a raw
testicle at some point in the 30 days if
i don't do it i'm gonna wear a teletubby
costume for a week straight can you eat
raw organs with your shadow no okay
start with the heart you can just chew
that that's raw heart
what do you say to that cheers huh
second grade liver this is where it gets
disgusting right nice especially liver
has a really strong taste
i can't do it
by the way here hunter do you want some
i ate before we came so uh-huh we're
done right all right testicle no
no
is it filled with cup yeah it's good for
you yeah all right i'll go
[Music]
well
but no i wasn't gonna give up yet i got
it as takeaway and eventually i'd eat it
after maybe working my way up for those
who don't want to put raw testicle or
raw blood in their mouth we built
hardened soil which is grass-fed grass
finish regeneratively raised desiccated
organs in capsules fresh organs are best
i don't want people to take the
supplements if they can do fresh organs
this all sounds crazy at first but it
seems like these are interesting points
i guess we'll see what my blood tests
show cholesterol testosterone but i
still want to see what other experts in
the research says the stakes of this
story are increasing get it because the
guess what i'm having for breakfast i'm
missing carbs a little bit then you also
miss normal bowel movements you always
got to bring that up now how long have
you been kind of probably six months to
a year what's your mud butt been like
since you've been doing it
i'm working myself up i just put some
liver in my ground beef oh it just hits
you after a while oh it's not too bad
right testicles are probably my favorite
sex drive you get at least eat a raw
test score too
i believe it is the morning of day nine
what are you eating now i want to say 85
to 90 animal products some fruits and
some vegetables mainly berries zucchini
squash and sweet potatoes as well just
because i think i need the fiber and i
talked to my doctor about it seems like
he's pretty open to it honestly i was i
was surprised about that cramping here
and there over the past few days but i
just feel like it's drastically improved
surprisingly so like i said i was a
little bit skeptical but i'm feeling
pretty good i don't want to make any
crazy claims as of now i don't know it
seems like such a crazy drastic diet but
is this really healthy and what does the
other side say have you ever wondered
what would happen if you put a carnivore
and a vegan in the same room well i did
too so grab your favorite popcorn i've
got my pork rinds the health claims
surrounding the diet are largely just
jumping the gun i think it's kind of
opposite that burning of proof is on
proving that it's not healthy and that
it's been how humans existed for
millions of years that's how we came and
then that's healthy is that true name
one species that doesn't eat a diet that
is involved that doesn't answer my
question like the whole premise that
meat is bad is like quite hilarious to
me because you're running with an appeal
to nature this is the simple truth of
nature i don't know what to say this is
like
how is that a simple truth of nature
that's actually just a red herring it
did well okay i have the simplest thesis
that whole foods are good luckily there
are studies to show
you can see it and i haven't seen that
very persuasively in the literature what
are you talking about oh man i knew this
would be fun i'm more confused than i
was before all these different sides
showing studies to support it is it
obvious to you now that the people from
that crowd don't know what the
they're talking about the guy is a clown
to be perfectly honest you know i had to
block him like you would just be making
insane statements basically a troll
that's some nonstop and obviously my
channel is not in depth at all don't
listen to me check out their stuff and
we have to acknowledge that there are
biases at play here does brian have a
bias because he's working on a
docu-series that is debunking game
changers maybe does nick have a bias
because he cares about animals and
doesn't want us to kill them potentially
do i have a bias to make the carnival
diet look better than it is of course
not thanks butcherbox for sponsoring
this video you can sign up with a link
below to get free ribeyes for a year
i absolutely love them but anyways my
point is how can you trust anyone how do
you know who's right what about the
ethics the environment and what i found
was fascinating and infuriating by this
time i had some good news normal [ __ ]
baby you've got nothing left to say now
what do you think of my skin how are
they looking better than before i think
so actually yeah if you told me a few
months ago that i would be eating only
meat and feeling this way i would have
believed you ground beef with liver and
hot now that i've had a taste of this i
might go carnivore you can also try some
liver supplements for hot and soil or
stuff like that link in the description
smooth
i was traveling for a few days to this
creative event i was invited to and
sticking to the diet was fine just had
to make some adjustments but i really
wonder how many animals have to die
every year if you go animal based and
what about the ethical and environmental
aspects i just want to ask ryan a
question what is true of humans that is
untrue of animals that if untrue of
humans would cause humans to lose value
sufficiently that we would be justified
in killing them and slaughtering them
for food the way to have the fewest
deaths would be carnivore if you wanted
to eat one cow you could eat that over
the course of a year maybe you would
take one and a half and one animal die
and hopefully that would be a grass-fed
cow that's out there just eating grass
and then it has one bad day and then you
eat it i just want everybody to know
that brian hasn't actually answered the
question animals are killed in every
single stage of the process of growing
plant-based species are relocated and
wiped out or killed and slaughtered to
grow the plants also true of animal
agriculture if you use regenerative
agriculture that doesn't use monocrops
then you'll kill less animals so i feel
morally superior to you because i kill
less animals that's my answer is that
i'm feeling less enough with my diet
okay this is also problematic that's
just an empirical play i just want the
audience to understand that he still
hasn't really answered the question
okay we're dumping literal hundreds of
millions of tons of synthetic fertilizer
on the land because we've made it so
infertile by growing plants we need more
cows
raised properly to regenerate all the
land that we have stripped of its
nutrients from years of monocrop farming
when cows poop and pee on the ground it
increases carbon increases the soil
microbiome you get green grass you get
ecosystems with bugs and birds the other
thing people will argue is you can't
scale return of agriculture you
absolutely can scale regenerative
agriculture totally scalable as long as
people vote with their dollars yes if
you eat meat make sure it's high quality
humanely raised no added hormones and
butcher box is all of that because the
more money flows into companies like
these the more the industry improves
because we vote without dollars
meanwhile i'm still on my quest to work
my way up to eating raw testicles but i
needed some help i'm here with kurt
you've been countable for how long four
years and he prepared a buffet for me
what is all this marrow bones half a
heart right here tongue this is straight
fat neck vertebra kidney this stuff is
so good so i'm just gonna put some salt
in there yeah it's like butter if you're
brave you could drink this juice
you ready cheers
oh
that bowl that i had in the closet i um
i ate the peanuts
yeah
we're not going to do that we had some
more hearts some more liver it's
actually pretty high in coenzyme q10 all
right the coenzyme
yeah but then came the kidney what does
a kidney do it filters your piss yeah it
kind of tastes like this oh yeah all
right
he's struggling too cheers
oh there's like these waves of taste
if i can eat this i could eat some
testosticals let's put this debate to an
end what is the actual sign saying what
are the studies well i read up on them
and i almost understood one paragraph
the iarc report found a 17 higher
colorectal cancer risk and there was a
dose-dependent relationship then it's
not even like it was small it was
two-thirds of a million participants
over 12.5 years of follow-up if you go
to the east if you do studies in asia
china thailand japan you see the
completely opposite correlation there's
a large study with over 240 000 people
the men that ate the most red meat had
the lowest rates of heart disease women
that eat the most red meat lowest rates
of cancer it seems like for every study
there's another study pointing the other
direction wow observational science junk
science giving people surveys 100 people
what did you eat over the last five
years we want you to recall we're basing
all of our rct's epidemiology food
questionnaires all this stuff based on
an unhealthy population eating processed
foods eating hot dogs with milkshakes
and sodas and candy and then we say the
hot dog is bad we've been told meat is
bad for you so who eats more meat people
that ride more motorcycles drink more
alcohol smoke more cigarettes get less
colonoscopies get less mammograms get in
the sun less don't play tennis on
sundays get out of this carnivore versus
vegan battle race that the food
companies are trying to make you sick
they don't care about your health the
food companies and the drug companies
work together to promote a culture where
you eat more you become sick from the
food and then you're dependent on the
methods heart association diabetes
associated cancer associations they are
in it to make money and push agendas the
top 10 donation organizations to public
medical education are food companies the
food companies own our education system
and they will never let go again it's
not a conspiracy it's just money who
pays for everything so now we can't even
fully trust the science and studies
because they have biases missing context
agendas you know how they say it takes
650 gallons to make beef burger patties
because cows need so much water well 94
of that is rain water that would fall on
the land regardless with or without cows
that's how they calculated but then on
the vegan side there's also great
channels going into detail debunking it
back with lots of studies and research
pointing back at it how can we trust
anyone or anything now especially when
you're someone like hudson whose health
is on the line but i believe that in the
end there is a simple answer to all of
this it is time
for my nemesis
[Music]
so this here is just part of the ball
here we meet again again thanks to
butcherbox for sponsoring this video
they don't sell testicles but they have
everything you could want and they're
supporting our channel as we're
expanding our team hiring editors and
operators and whatnot and i'm grateful
to have them as a partner i told hunter
i was going to do it if i'm not going to
do it i have to wear a purple teletubby
costume for a week it's delivered
directly to your door frozen and fresh
super high quality go sign up with the
link below to get free revise for a year
there's one of these moments where the
more you hesitate the worse it gets
right
i did it
it wasn't too bad i mean it might be the
salmon you should go straight for it
like grab the testicle eat it from the
skin
oh this hit different oh no
oh that is just yeah that's a different
experience
so again if you don't want to eat
testicles for whatever reason i don't
understand that you can check out hot
and soil uh link in the description do
you feel the difference
yeah it's like you know that feeling of
like when you haven't had sex in a while
like that's the i don't know that
feeling
now before we go into the final results
of this diet and check on my cholesterol
testosterone and overall health i want
to make it clear that i'm very biased
towards meat i've been eating meat my
whole life and i wanted to focus on the
animal-based arguments because it's a
new perspective but i'm not advocating
for any diet and you shouldn't listen to
me
all i want is to start a conversation
look who's getting in on the party
that's right the veggie eater i just
couldn't resist your meat so it seems
like you're more open to it now i'm not
open to this super restriction but i
really like some of the concepts you
know like i i'm gonna start eating more
organ meats i admire the people who try
the extremes whether it's carnivore
fruitarian even breatharian they might
be wrong but they always push the
conversation forward and we need them
because oftentimes they learn something
that everyone can benefit from like a
wim hof who did crazy experiments but he
taught us the amazing benefits of cold
exposure and breadth work and he started
an entire movement there are many people
who disagree with me which is good it
means we're starting to have productive
conversation in society don't get mad if
you don't agree we cannot agree it's
okay it's been over 30 days now how do
you feel so far i'd say overall in
comparison to other diets that i've
eaten i mean it's definitely been one of
the best definitely opened up my eyes to
the fact that meat is not your enemy and
moving forward we both want to continue
to eat an ancestral diet where we add in
honey sweet potato fruit which includes
things like avocado squash zucchini yes
those are fruits i guess it's similar to
what you were just saying which is just
a strict modified version of paleo and
instead of eating plants and vegetables
we get our micronutrients from eating
liver right getting the blood test and
dexa scan 30 days isn't really enough
but like you see changes it's crazy it's
great let's rock and roll the most
interesting part is the hdl we talk
about good cholesterol bad cholesterol
if your hdl is greater than 65 and you
have a very healthy metabolism and very
very low risk for cardiovascular disease
it's not a huge change i wasn't
expecting any change but in 30 days you
dropped your crp testosterone really
hard test to judge it depends on what
time of day you've taken and it can vary
this just reflects a healthy
testosterone despite not really a
dramatic change in your training regimen
you put on four and a half pounds of
muscle it's very hard to put on muscle
not only did you put on the muscle you
lost fat just eating more meat this is
all great but i wish i could give you a
clear answer on who's right and who's
wrong but the world just isn't that
black and white it's gray with many
shades nuances and biases all we can do
is be open-minded question everything
embrace uncertainty and try things until
we find what works for us thanks for
watching